I just want to get your action to tweet
by Gary lineker at the footballer who's
taken issue with the scheme on moral
grounds he's said there is no huge
influx we take far fewer refugees than
other major European countries this is
just an immeasurably cruel policy
directed at the most vulnerable people
in language that's not dissimilar to
that used by Germany in the 30s and I'm
out of order
well firstly on the language that he
uses I think that is inflammatory and
wrong you shouldn't throw around
comparisons with the Nazis and 1930s
Germany he should choose his language
carefully just as politicians should do
and I suspect he's been in the public
eye long enough to know exactly the kind
of reaction that he was going to provoke
but on the policy he's also wrong
because unlike Gary lineker I see every
day in my job what the evil people
smuggling gangs are actually doing and
that's right what they do is cruel and
heartless what he's talking people are
dying as a result of their activities
and the only way to break their business
model is to implement a policy so
talking about though is that we take
fewer refugees than other major European
countries and actually if you look at
applications made in 2021 per head per
100 000 population you know we are quite
a long way down at the list aren't we
and Germany France Switzerland
Netherlands Spain well it depends how
you how you look at the figures I mean
if you look at the homes for Ukraine
scheme that is that's not that is twice
the size of the French equivalent just
you're just using one example of deaf
people I think it's great overall it's a
really significant scheme you're talking
about yeah 150 000 I'm talking about the
overall Refugee
decided okay let me answer and let me
answer a different way then if you look
at the countries who take people on safe
and legal routes organized by the unhcr
we are the fourth largest recipient of
those individuals of any developed
countries
overall figures you're looking at well
I'm looking at the countries in terms of
how would you measure a country's
willingness to embrace those people who
are in greatest Eden
referees another major European
countries well I don't think that's
correct I mean obviously there are
countries like Poland who borders you
know their position within Europe means
that inevitably very large numbers of
people have crossed them they've
welcomed them in a compassionate manner
but the schemes that we have put forward
in recent years are incredibly generous
and compassionate and that will always
continue you're still going to watch
much of the day
yeah of course I will I like watching
Gary lineker I just don't always enjoy
his tweets and think he should choose
his language more carefully okay thank
you very much thank you